two weeks ago he texted me
how are you
what are you doing are you are you uh
doing stand-up
and i answered him with you know much
too many words
and then i didn't hear back
and then last week
last week i got a text
and it just said i love you
and i didn't say much back i just said i
love you norm
and that was my last communication with
him
but he didn't mince words and he didn't
mince emotions
so he wasn't out doing [ __ ]
he wasn't just out to
you know oh here's the emotional moment
in the telethon where we pretend we're
feeling something so we can uh
one of the gifts of my life is that he
loved me
and that i loved him
hell i'm always gonna love him i mean
there's not another guy like this guy
i've had this
gnawing regret
uh this last day and a half and it's
reading all this praise for norm which
again i
believe is completely justified yeah and
will endure
um
and
it's been a regret that
um
he had he didn't get to experience this
you know he took
so much flack in his career he took so
much [ __ ]
um and yes he knew that he had fans
but
uh
i wish
you know it's a common wish for people
but i wish he had been able to read
the stuff that's being written about him
i wish he knew how beloved he is and
also um
how uh
in awe comedians are yeah of of what he
did and what he meant and how
um
[Music]
you know how important he was to the
people who are probably the most
important people in the world to him
yeah you know and he uh you know i wish
i wish he knew that and and that's the
one regret i i
uh
you know he kept
he kept his illness
a complete secret from everybody
everybody and
um
and that was his choice and i respect
that choice see how it's done but
selfishly for me
i wish
i had had the chance and i i wish
a lot of us wish we had the chance to go
in and tell him yeah you are a
singular
artist and you've really made a huge
difference and you've i mean
if nothing else uh
i don't
i don't know if anybody
that could make me laugh like that you
know because so many people like pretend
that they don't give a [ __ ]
you know
both in my business and in other
businesses you got to be i don't give a
[ __ ] hey you know me i don't give a [ __ ]
you know those people that advertise
them like that guy clearly in the best
way didn't give a [ __ ] he really cared
about people and stuff but like
like he did what he wanted to do
and when he was on snl how big a gig
that was
because there was so few channels the
internet hadn't blown up yet and even
with basic cable and everything i mean
it was still if you were on saturday
night live
and you were doing weekend update it was
one of the most coveted gigs
a comedian could have and you were part
of this
lineage of you know at that point it was
uh
you know
chevy
chase um jane curtin right on through to
dennis miller's reign when he did it and
you know i did colin quinn come after i
think colin came after but it was always
just like the best of the best comics
that they had doing it and continued on
with tina fey and all of them
and
no one's walking away from that job
i mean if some suit at nbc tells you
they don't like the jokes you're doing
and be funnier
you know you're shaking in your i would
i would be i'd be like oh [ __ ] you know
i'm going to lose this big gig i don't
want to get fired i don't want to piss
these people off or whatever
i guess he was doing all those oj jokes
and somebody i forget how the story went
there was somebody there that knew oj or
something and
was telling him telling norm to back off
and move on to something else
so what does norm do he just doubles
down and he just does even more
oj jokes
which is like
you know
the balls that that took to do that and
he ended up losing the gig he got fired
and he was and people loved him he was
[ __ ] hilarious but he you know
he didn't back down to the to the big
[ __ ] guy over there and he ended up
losing the gig
so
you know as luck would have it
i think it was dirty work came out like
a year and a half later or so
so he has to promote it and he's on the
press thing so lauren has him back and
has him host the show
and i remember he went out there in his
opening joke
this opening joke he just comes out
and he was just like
yeah yeah something something like this
was yes good to be back you know i
actually got fired from this show
about a year and a half ago because they
said it wasn't funny and uh now here i
am
i'm hosting the show so that means one
of two things
either i got a lot funnier
or this show sucks
[Music]
and one of the things that speaks to
you know i i
uh was having a conversation with um
jim downey uh
and and in the in the wake of norm's
death and
jim downey and i was trying to get to
the what is it that made norm so
different and he reminded me said you
know on weekend update
we would do um
there's a dress rehearsal which i know
because i've worked at sarnot live
there's a dress rehearsal and he said
the best way to test a joke on weekend
update
is at dress rehearsal if it does well at
dress rehearsal it will do well on air
uh if it doesn't do well at dress
rehearsal it will bomb on air that's
that's the best way to test it
and he said
that norm would do a joke at dress
rehearsal
that they both loved and it would get
nothing
and when weekend update was over jim
would say
um
yeah it's too bad that joke didn't do
well and norm would say like yeah i know
we got to do it. so he would do jokes
that he knew
were going to get nothing yeah if he
thought the joke was worthwhile
he didn't give a [ __ ]
now
that
is very uncommon that is very well he
never pandered he didn't pander at all
and
that takes um
you know that's what made me think about
the line you said so many years ago andy
like it almost terrifies me his
fearlessness because
it was
um the thing he did
so many times on our show which i
thought was absolutely
outrageous
was um
he would
launch into these long stories that you
later you quickly realized
were farmers
daughter jokes
shaggy dogs shaggy dog stories yeah just
absolute horseshit absolutely [ __ ]
stories and he would go on and on and on
and i'm so happy that um
the moth joke has been getting
circulated so much from our tonight show
because
it is completely outrageous what he's
doing uh it is um you know it's it's the
it's the tonight show
and he is telling this very long story
and he's taking all the time in the
world
and
i love it just because
even though i was there
i'm delighted every time i see it yeah i
i every time i see it i'm delighted with
it because
what he's doing is breaks every rule
you're not you're not
brevity is the soul of wit that is the
rule keep it you know and
man he completely
like picasso blew up the form
he goes and he tells this joke forever
and then finally gets to this
punch line
you can see
that
he's everyone's delighted uh but he has
broken every rule in the book
and
i was
asking
i was talking to laurie joe
uh and i asked her if it's okay if i
related this and she said it was okay
but she said that not too long ago
um
someone asked norm
about the moth story that he told on on
our tonight show and that
that she said what made the guy want to
know what made you have the nerve to do
that
and that he said
that
you know is that goddamn frank smiley
he said i was only supposed to do one
segment
and then suddenly in the commercial
break frank came over and said like
you're doing another one because
whenever i had norm i was greedy i
wanted more norm i always wanted more
norm and
so
he didn't know that he was that we were
going to ask him do a second segment he
had nothing planned
absolutely nothing planned
so as recently as like
not that long ago i think it was a
couple of months ago he was telling
somebody uh
damn it
was frank smiley hey get back out there
conan rocks more so he heard that joke
from colin quinn
and
he did the segment and it was he had
seven minutes prepared yeah and um
and so he
basically um
you said you know and then he's done he
didn't say we'll be right back with more
norm and he goes i've got nothing to say
yeah yeah so then he uh
he remembered the column joke
and it was a 20-second joke so he asked
you
how long is the segment
and he was hoping you'd say 20 seconds
right but you said seven minutes yeah
yeah so it became a seven minute job
yeah yeah and he's doing that this has
to be understood he's doing this on the
fly
so his way to slow it down that he came
up with on the fly
is he invents
it's a check off it's a check off play
russian names with russian names and
there's a sadness an ineffable sadness
in life weighing on the character's soul
and
and i'm thinking
you know uh who
i've never met anybody
who would take that chance
uh and make that choice and i'll never
meet anybody like him again he was the
ballsiest comedian in the history of
comedians
he look he was taking that and he was
saying like the joke doesn't matter like
that you know he would
watching that seeing that clip again
you're you're getting to see his brain
he's just showing you his brain and the
notion that this is that the joke is the
thing the joke isn't the thing no it's
the journey taking a stroll through this
guy's brain and hearing the choices that
he makes and what he has to say
and
you know and i think that that was like
kind of what like there was so much of
like what he you know would say like
well that doesn't matter this matters
you know and and what mattered to him
was his own self-expression was his own
was spreading his own kind of genius in
his own point of view like there's a
clip out he did some roast
and
i and i remember seeing it at the time i
can't remember who it was that he was
roasting but all his jokes was bob saget
was it bob saget and it was unbelievable
it was it but all the jokes were things
like you know bob often has a lot of
things on or you know bob often has
things on his mind it's when he's
wearing a hat like it was all these dads
intentionally bombed right and then i i
didn't even know this but i remember
feeling like
okay norm i mean
you know these are funny and this is and
you're funny doing because you can't
help but be funny but this is feels a
little hostile you know like why are why
are you breaking from what this you know
you were invited
to a costume party and you came you know
in a tuxedo you know whatever he didn't
play by the rules of the thing turns out
the producers told him really go for it
really get him and norm was like
ah yeah you're gonna tell me what to do
here i'll do this i'll do the softest
lamest dad jokes i can come up with yeah
and it was just a [ __ ] you to the
producers
it was looked weird at the time it was
funny in a way but it still was just
like it was norm doing what the [ __ ] he
wanted to do it was still hilarious yeah
yeah norm is it's like norm couldn't not
be funny yeah